astrazeneca nouvelles sources de rupture
au sein de l'union européenne
parmi les points de désaccord l'âge des
personnes auxquelles le vaccin peut être
administré au royaume uni il faisait la
fierté du gouvernement
mais le doute a fini par l'emporter il
faut désormais avoir plus de 30 ans pour
se faire vacciner
la france la belgique on fixer cet âge à
55 ans tandis que l'espagne l'italie les
pays-bas l'allemagne et le portugal
l'on fixé à 60 ans en europe seules
l'islande a choisi une limite d'âge à 70
ans et malgré les avis favorable du
régulateur européen et de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
le danemark a décidé hier de renoncer
définitivement au vaccin astrazeneca
nous avons choisi aujourd'hui de
poursuivre le déploiement de vaccins
sont astrazeneca
ce n'est pas parce que nous pensons que
c'est un mauvais vaccin nous sommes
d'accord avec l'évaluation de l'om à
notre décision est donc contextuelle et
spécifiques à la situation particulière
du danemark
sachant que nous avons vacciné la
plupart de notre population à risque que
nous déployons le vaccin avec un volume
très élevé même si nous continuons sans
le vaccin d'astrazeneca et que nous
avons également un très bon contrôle de
notre pandémie si le danemark est devenu
le premier pays d'europe à abandonner le
vaccin il pourrait ne pas être le
dernier
la commissaire européenne à la santé
adapter le 7 avril dernier les 27 pays
membres à parler d'une seule voix pour
ne pas nourrir la défiance autour
d'astrazeneca
un appel qui pour le moment n'a pas été
entendu le secrétaire d'état chargé des
affaires européennes clément boon a lui
aussi pointé du doigt un nom de
coordination au sein de l'union
européenne
j'ai un regret c'est qu'il n'y avait pas
de robe de la santé au début de la crise
je suis pour une europe de la santé pour
qu'on ait des décisions communes qui
nous permettent de réagir vite et
groupes et les différents changements de
cap concernant l'avenir d'astrazeneca
dans les campagnes de vaccination risque
de retarder le retour à la vie normale
paradoxal quand on sait que les
laboratoires peine encore à livrer les
pays demandeurs dans les délais